It should be clear now that the first
question to consider, in terms of,
Botnet C&C Design is, how can
the bots contact their master safely?
In other words,
in a stealthy and robust way.
And as we have just discussed,
a naive approach is not adequate.
For example, if we have
hard-coded the malware to include
a single IP address of our
command control server,
then when this IP address has been
identified by security admins.
The network admins such
as admins in the ISP
can block all traffic to this server.
Therefore, no command
control traffic for
the bots can be reached to
the file master's server.
And as a result,
the whole botnet's intercepted.
For example, if all the bots come to
a single IP address that's hard-coded in
the bot malware, then when this IP
address is identified by secured admins,
the network admins, for example those at
ISP, can block all traffic to this IP.
Therefore, blocking all
command control traffic and
disrupting the operations of the botnet.
And because such naive approach
is not stealthy nor robust,
it is only used by script-kiddies and
first-time malware authors.
In addition to safety, utility is
also very important to the Botmaster.
In other words, a Botmaster wants
efficient and reliable communications,
so that he can reach and coordinate
enough bots to perform a specific task.
So to summarize the design
considerations of Botnet C&C,
the Botmaster would want efficient and
reliable communication.
That is the ability to reach a sizable
set of bots within certain time limit.
Stealthy communication, so
that it is hard to detect C&C traffic.
Resilient or robust communication, so
that it is very hard to disable or
block C&C traffic.